no else is out you're doing crazy like
this you're working I'm willing to put
this on my skin you can buy some skin
[Music]
that's all the guys from phase here and
my table boys
[Music]
the Tyson's of face crime smells may be
the only chance the Guardian comes back
in India to the Stillwater girls got my
multiple the piece come in forgot it
will not stop one more to go and
Guardian yes then all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to tell phase clans story we have to
bring you back to May 2010 when phase
sniping made their YouTube debut back
then they were a Call of Duty sniping
clan founded by three players clips
housecat and resistance the trio
garnered a reputation for elevating the
art of trickshotting by adding 360s
noscopes ladder stalls and weapon
switching to the already established
content mind that was quick scope videos
trickshotting had existed in the past
but phase were one of the first groups
to do it as a team and their YouTube
content took off when fakie one of the
world's most popular trickshot heirs
have joined the team it was during that
era when phase unveiled their beloved
ill cams team Taj series on YouTube that
generation of gaming on YouTube wasn't
just about being the best it was about
looking cool while doing it and it was
that finesse that became phase clans
calling card in 2014 temper who was
running a lot of phases operation at the
time had new phase member banks move in
with him
my hometown and we decided to just stick
opportunity to give collab and do a
whole other stuff for you guys for his
fans and it was then in Boston that
phase began pairing lifestyle content
with their growing gaming brand phase
the morning guys this is my 100th video
upload this is my second day in the life
it was that swagger that drew the
attention of some of cod eSports biggest
names and ushered in one of the greatest
rivalries in the history of eSports faze
clan versus optic gaming 3-phase were in
complete control and out of nowhere
I'll take they just went cue rod of
applause for an eight shot in many ways
phase and optic were one in the same
they both made video content around Call
of Duty and provided their players with
a platform to promote themselves this
way the brand succeeds the players
succeed and names like phase and optic
become household names phase entered
Call of Duty eSports around the black
ops 2 era and didn't exactly burst onto
the scene as they failed to win a series
outside of the Open bracket at MLG
winter and at that MLG spring event the
team would face off against optic for
the first time at a major tournament we
have an amazing matchup in front of it
they have another challenge in front of
them and that challenge is optic gaming
the green wall can they topple the green
wall Benson the first three maps are all
stand up this is a minute or two
and it'll ever be what leaky with a
two-piece on the army all you need to do
at this point is call it out to his
teammates he's gonna go for the zoo we
go there as well
Scott B connects with members from there
I don't think he expected that but he
try to hunt down the face way shoot eyes
in the back nice play can refurbish
completely so find a second on the hill
not gonna happen
Bob dick would get the best of face as
MLG spring served as the first in a long
line of defeats at the hands of their
bitter rivals but after another roster
change were ready to take on a new look
optic gaming roster at UMG philadelphia
in a gripping five-game set we actually
have one player left alive it's three
seconds left
ricky-ricky surveys will have taken the
W him in what an amazing game from both
teams
hey holy will comes down to it you just
got to do what you got to do what a game
what a game face what a game ends up
taking it in a nail-biting matchup here
I say I just like to say fold it it was
one of their first major upsets in cod
eSports and it came against their
greatest rival and even though they
didn't win the event it set the pace for
the team going forward it was only later
in 2014 that phase would finally catch
the wind in their sails those you didn't
hear today we have officially dropped
nameless from the squad and picked up
proof B and with the addition of proof e
to their lineup they became a major
contender in Call of Duty eSports and
made it further at the Call of Duty
World Championships 2014 US regional and
optics
but world's was a different story optic
were able to best phase and finish in
third while Peruvian ko finished in six
but phase rebounded and started to
change some strong finishes together
which only helped the YouTube side of
their business the fandom surrounding
faze clan their Cod team and their
rivalry with optic was growing and it
had only just begun move up and get map
control as it is for the offense because
the b-bomb site for example is closer
know one thing that I think changed it a
lot on defense is you know the offensive
team able a strong arm stun denial wins
they're done Vickie's wins last map and
you see said that right there with a
head shot through the wall on a replays
and now can go 3-1 face can go up face
actually tie this to two right now with
a win from a people this is the biggest
round of the tournament for both of
these teams and players are you serious
right now
after world face brought home their
first significant titles UMG nashville
2014 and the cod league season one
regular season title but their team was
constantly ravaged by roster shuffling
and it was only as Call of Duty advanced
warfare came out that they would finally
build a statement roster sensor and
apathy were joined by slasher and a
player that would go on to define phase
cod Alex what did you do to change
things here this tournament I don't say
anything but I was X was not only a
highly touted player in his own right
but had developed a reputation as optic
gaming's kryptonite making him a perfect
fit for faze the team attended advanced
Warfare's first event at MLG columbus
2014 in pursuit of a trophy but after
making their way to the winner's bracket
tragedy struck as akes severely cut his
hand mid tournament but Eakes had a
title in his sights and he wasn't going
to let anything get in his way
I wanna hop up overtakes
he's gonna be playing or sick you got to
warm up I think he's a seer now just
showed up man I'm hoping the best for
him and after making their way through
the bracket stage only one team stood
between them and the trophy optic game
the series started and aches was up to
his old tricks rewarding optics gonna
take it from apathy and here we go
eight nothing this one looking all but
over a boy's face turning up in a plank
in a brand-new game with their best
lineup faze clan had finally defeated
optic on Cod's biggest stage phase had
to do it twice to best-of-five he was
during the 2015 season that the optic
phase rivalry fully spilled over optic
look flawless throughout most of the
year while faze stumbled out of the gate
but the intensity of the rivalry fueled
phase even amidst one of the most
dominant years in optics history face
clad only dropping two
the entire weekend honestly just looking
after Dallas face took another title
from optic at gfinity summer and it was
during that time that phase and optic
were considered the two best teams and
Call of Duty for the first time ever
phasing out people going back and forth
for a long time with like sniping
trickshotting all that kind of stuff
they've always been like the two biggest
team so people just kind of saw him as
rivals but now for the first time ever
phase and optic are pretty much the two
top three top teams in the game phase
and optic are two of the top teams in
competitive called do right now this is
not really happened before phase and
optic have not always been like the best
or considered the best at the same time
in a real game but phase would get
bested in their final bout against optic
in advanced warfare marking a
disappointing end to what many argue was
phase Cod's most defining year next up
for phase was the release of black ops 3
and the announcement of the call of duty
world league in 2016 the biggest step
cod had ever made in their eSports
trajectory since that heralded phase
optic era of 2015 faze clan and Call of
Duty hasn't been able to return to the
top of their game but make no mistake
this organization will always be at the
heart of the Call of Duty scene while
faze clan was rising to prominence and
Call of Duty
the organization sees the opportunity to
branch out into another massive FPS
title Counter Strike global Offensive
faze clan acquired g2 esports csgo Ross
report reported $700,000 in January 2016
and began their voyage into the game's
burgeoning eSports scene and it was at
their first event at Dreamhack Leipzig
in 2016 where they showed that they
could hang with some of the game's best
even though they failed to make it out
of groups it's got to come right now
will it be enough well they don't have a
kit so they can't just hold it down this
mom is not gonna buy a significant
amount of time they also know where my
killer Lee is they're gonna have to try
and go for me of that Wallis are still
burning in sight Marky letting wins the
first part again soos they don't have a
kit they might not have time Mikey let
it go
some down my killer they're picking up a
triple kill FX is checking from behind
over they lied alright
today's to finish the 2016 was a growing
year four phases counter-strike roster
they managed to take a 9th 12th finish
at the year's first major in Columbus
actually winning that fight knees down
took L we once you're in the corner and
they know you're there in simple saw him
the first time that's not a very good
position any longer so huge play coming
out Aranea with that double kill my
killer lee inside the a bomb site he's
gonna get shut down by he co but AC is
there and actually Alicia's gonna be
getting a so he go getting a team kill
on the leash
is he going down but he did this damage
to help out rain coming in he gets one
more kill for the quad with four health
left a fifth six finish at Dreamhack
Bucharest but how soon does he use it
because they're gonna go one versus
three honor this he's gonna push them on
four seconds thrown it early enough he
can hold through this to get the defuse
just barely and another 9/12 finish at
ESL one cologne
the year's second major crimson long
indicates they're likely gonna go on
this because he'll just wait to anchor
the position good shot from AZ to start
it off though that's one of the awp
still with vision he's got to fnatic is
he finds Dennis Byrd board for AZ as he
jumps over and find flash' in the lead
up to e League season to a shook up
their roster by signing former stralla
Tsai GL Kerrigan ahead of the 2017
season much like with their call of duty
roster BAE's have become known as an
organization that wasn't afraid to shake
up their roster to achieve the results
their fans expected and with Kerrigan on
board they look strong at 2017 s
inaugural major phase were bested in the
brackets by SK gaming but showed that
with Kerrigan they were capable of
competing at the game's highest level so
the core element that changed with phase
two make what should have been an
experiment or concept team but will not
ultimately should have failed as an
experiment and take that and make it
into one of the best teams in the world
was adding in this player Kerrigan who's
won the all time great csgo in-game
leaders and then kid the era of the
Bosnian beast
Mouse's by is gonna be torn away from
them very very quickly by side
my god shocks then that's just to find
one more the money isn't gonna touch him
and what on earth has just happened his
deagle is on fire a walking shoe as well
Nico is on fire considered to be one of
the best young players in the world
Nicola Nico Kovach joined faze clan in a
blockbuster signing that shook the
counter-strike world and just what he
can pull off the multi frags he can do
the way that he approaches the game he's
one of those players you know we always
talk about being at being a top player
and it's gonna be exciting so he can do
in this phase roster and they wasted no
time showing just how great they could
be winning starladder season 3 on the
back of a stellar performance from their
newest superstar one of the best players
in the world this is a very totaled over
the opens up world gets to the a quickly
without response he's an acquaintance
janani coach got all three Nico was just
waiting without the armor how are they
able to break through they just can't
[Music]
because he's already free down Nico's
gonna get both as he walks in fb9
undetected but 2017 second major was a
different story
Ct covered all seven seconds gone
they're Russian taps awaits an evil good
time on the peak good damage he's here
as well as he goes to the pistol and a
crossfire established thirteen rounds
four big no terrorist rounds one yet by
phases five have gone by in the way of
the CTS Nico has to Sanders crowd
electronic on the high ground himself
Last Man Standing the bomb is down again
the one versus one is Kerrigan the
in-game leader The Talisman parfaits can
he can't do it please visit the flipside
hello have finally done it 16 to 10
they've taken over the line they had so
many
to do it that has to be highest
expectation and worst outcome that I've
seen in recent memory as a major
absolutely if you consider the way that
they're building in towards this major
it's it's really insane isn't it after
an O and three group stage exit phase
knew that changes needed to be made and
in classic phase fashion their way of
handling it was to make a massive move
after Krakow phase acquired both Olaf
Olaf Meister khyber and Lana slab
Guardian Kovach to assemble the biggest
super team in modern csgo history to put
that much star power on a team at once
was unprecedented and sent a clear
message to the csgo community phase
didn't want to sit around and develop an
in-house roster they wanted to win now
and at ESL New York they made sure that
everyone knew that Bay's clan was the
team to beat they should be able to hold
it off
mental if they lose like this it would
be a disaster but what a play from Nikko
on North American soil is quit it's
another Killbuck arrogance fast to get
him high JDM who opened off the kills
still-liquid have a chance with the men
failures have gotta be careful of the
smoke that's down and Kerrigan continues
on could form rain looking for blood and
he gets four head shots at so far the
racks quarter and then eco well in the
way as he goes back to sandwich I don't
know how they do this now they're gonna
pull one other girl smokes and
flashbangs us about it drank an arsenal
to where the fire box at hope of a kill
all in in one position at Guardian makes
it to the side the flash and Niko
fittingly gets the last killer's face
dominate New York in 2017 the Barclays
Center all the way through this
tournament they've looked so worked so
good and they'll let the new boys get
the trophy Guardians done this before
Olof joins him
Faye's would close up 2017 by hammering
home that message after New York they
want you need 2017 spray play second at
IEM Oakland they're up against Nikko one
of the wall city finds a three man spray
down olofmeister charming and I think
that's it we're absolutely done an
inferno and it will be faith tying up
the series second at the ESL pro league
season six finals falling gets close
he's perfectly positioned above the bonk
so long as he hasn't lost five minutes
better way to do it I thought he might
not get toward it second time fallens
died misspoke trying to defuse and
another important round rain finds to it
face have a lead and won it all at the
ECS finals flashing not even close to
blinding up JD still continues on with
the AWP it's quite remarkable event to
the pistol and then to the wing he is
playing out of his mind right now but to
truly prove they were the best they had
to win a major and the super teams of
first shot to do that was at the
beginning of 2018 in Boston they're one
of the favorites to win the whole thing
so more or less for them this is just a
weight is actually great for phase in
the sense that they actually get to play
some official games phase lived up to
their expectations early dominating
their competition on you to a grand
finals berth but it was there where
Goliath would come face to face with
David cloud9
were a team of destiny and not even a
super team with some of the world's best
players could get in their way comes
back in Oh God - this your board seat
over Conway must want the puzzle piece
coming back Guardian will not stop one
more to go
yes then all see Carrigan leaving
Estrada's turret as well he fell off the
bridge and he's trying to do so
relentless aggression doesn't matter
what the situation are that's 30 but it
is country TK
[Applause]
sup he's [ __ ] up but up my float has
been taken out but he's the only man
standing between cloud line and the
major it's gonna be a double piece the
ring and everything
guardian waits patiently as pow my
sensor pushup
[Applause]
despite failing to win a major the team
has become a household name in the scene
they've got that vintage phase swagger
and prove that they can replicate the
infectious allure a phase fandom that
started back in the cod days as long as
the game they're playing allows you to
style on them phase will step up and
show you that they know how to do that
best it's this content first culture
this sort of irreverent we don't give a
[ __ ] but we'll still clown on you
attitude that has launched faze clan
into the stratosphere as of late with
the onset of the Battle Royale boom the
skyrocketing popularity of twitch and
the personality driven content that face
at the bar for the brand thrived what
[Music]
face had always told the line of gaming
and reality television but now those two
things have become more or less one in
the same
Faye's took their first step into player
unknowns battlegrounds during the games
boom in late 2017 they invested in an
eSports team but also sponsored
streamers and it's this intersection
between the competitive side of games
and twitch that made phase the perfect
Battle Royale or they already knew how
to turn competitive gaming into content
and well that's what battle Royales were
built around shouts my partner to you
field good stuff Turner
alright TiVoed buy you cloak see with
the hot carry dude and of course nothing
embodies that more than fortnight when
it became clear that fortnight was the
biggest game in the world BAE's was
quick to jump on board they signed a
team that would compete but would mainly
focus on streaming as is the fortnight
way in the short time that fortnight has
been around phase has cemented itself as
the go-to organization for both
competitive and entertainment phase
content all eyes may have been on the
likes of ninja myth and Tim the tap man
when the game first blew up but phase
has been one of the only organizations
to solidify itself as a significant part
of the games zeitgeist the game is
glamorous it's in your face it's loud
and it makes a lot of money after all
that's what phase is all about what is
wrong with you let's get some food let's
get some drinks this has of course been
spearheaded by one of the world's most
famous fortnight's streamers and pro
players T foo
crypto killer with $100 donation holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] did
[Music]
hello buddy
are you doing in there the ex h1z1 star
has become synonymous with phases
fortnight brand he was signed on to
partner with cloak as phases premier
competitive fortnight duo but has since
blown up into a name that rivals the
likes of ninja in the world of fortnight
and in classic phase fashion the kids
got game 2 Tipu is regarded by many as
the world's best competitive fortnight
player and this was further reinforced
back in October of 2018 at twitchcon
when he and cloak competed at the Fort
nightfall skirmish finals
it was there where the two teammates put
on a show to remember
you've got Snoopy snoot of the high
ground as well he's got that walls teeth
blue cloak see with another cloaks he's
still alive member coming into this day
were already first in points after Game
one there's one four o'clock seat cloaks
he's still in this thing looks like teef
who may have been eliminated earlier but
cloaks he's got four limbs and as I
think that's a pit that's fifth hope see
now five himself rosie has been putting
on a show I'm telling you he's the MVP
they absolutely dominated they showed
that they were in a league of their own
and they went home with the $400,000 top
prize
[Applause]
right next to them in second place was
yet another member of phase Nate hill
and with phase fortnight being the most
hype brand doing the brunt of the
winning in the world's most popular game
the phase lifestyle brand has reached
Heights we never knew a gaming org could
they've recently collaborated with
champion for exclusive phase clothing
that sold out in seconds and they
changed that into a wild signing phase
boat you may have saw lil yachty make
the announcement that he was officially
joining faze clan well we're here to
tell you that the rumors are indeed true
faze boat is official faze clan has
truly done it all in the gaming world
and well a wild amount outside of that
sphere as well if anyone deserves credit
for changing the mold in this weird
vision of gaming and entertainment and
watching people rage on the internet as
a TV like activity it's them they've
turned to headshots and 360s and jumping
off high places and wearing expensive
clothes and partying and call of duty
into things that are somehow closely
related and when you take a closer look
it's all kind of beautiful because when
you see someone faze up you know what
that means this is a brand that
transcends the FPS genre and gaming
itself it's both simple and complicated
all at once a whirlwind of bling and
options BAE's clan
you
[Music]